[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo desde el golpe de estado del
pasado primero de febrero el ejército de
mianmar ha llevado a cabo una campaña de
represión contra quienes los rechazan
desde la implementación de cortes de
internet que la población ha sabido
evadir hasta leyes que le otorgan
poderes para censurar el discurso en
línea en france 24 hablamos con testigos
directos de esta situación empezamos
el pasado primero de febrero el ejército
birmano llevó a cabo un golpe de estado
en mi amar y detuvo a la líder de facto
onza en sushi y otros altos funcionarios
elegidos democráticamente en noviembre
de 2020 los militares alegaron que hubo
fraude en dichos comicios y anunciaron
que devolvería en el poder después de
unas nuevas elecciones pero esto no
gustó a los ciudadanos de un país que
apenas había visto nacer la democracia
en 2011 cuando se puso fin a 49 años de
regímenes militares en rechazo al golpe
la población lanzó una campaña de
desobediencia civil una serie de
protestas y huelgas que se extendieron
por todo el país pero la represión
contra las movilizaciones ha dejado
decenas de muertos en el país de acuerdo
con naciones unidas y centenares de
personas han sido arrestadas según
cifras de activistas
internet ha jugado un papel fundamental
durante estas protestas pero la junta
militar ordenó la restricción del
servicio para impedir que las personas
reportaron sobre el golpe según los
ciudadanos birmanos desde la una de la
mañana y hasta las nueve de la mañana el
servicio de internet queda totalmente
apagado así también lo confirmó el
observatorio de telecomunicaciones net
blogs estos apagones generan
preocupación debido a las redadas
nocturnas en las que el ejército ha
realizado detenciones el resto del
tiempo se puede acceder a internet pero
las redes sociales están restringidas
algunos recurren a redes privadas
virtuales conocidas como vi pienso o vpn
para evadir los controles pero los
militares también bloquearon las
proyecciones gratuitas de estos
servicios las redes de mensajería
encriptada también son una opción
desde mi amar uno de los manifestantes
cuya identidad ni ubicación no
revelaremos para proteger su integridad
nos contó que otros métodos utilizan
para organizarse y algunos de nosotros
tenemos acceso a ello a través de
tarjetas sim que se usan para viajes
tarjetas simple tailandia
así algunos de nosotros podemos ver
noticias pero la mayoría no puede
después de las nueve de la mañana no
podemos acceder a redes sociales como
facebook instagram o twitter a través de
nuestros métodos usuales así que tenemos
que usar en el cliente incluso servicios
premium de pippen
si bien es la única manera cómo podemos
comunicarnos entre nosotros a través de
las redes por ahora
no vemos ninguna señal de que esto
terminará en los próximos días dos meses
en el facebook es la red social más
usada de mi amada tras el golpe de
estado la empresa bloqueó todas las
páginas controladas por los militares
privándolos de su mayor plataforma de
comunicaciones la compañía había sido
criticada por no hacer nada frente a la
forma en que el ejército ha usado la
plataforma
para incitar el odio contra la minoría
musulmana rohingya facebook es la
herramienta preferida de comunicación en
el país pero ahora instagram y twitter
son ampliamente usadas para reportar al
mundo lo que está pasando en mi ámbar
con numerales como whatsapp en en
mianmar y here the voice of myanmar que
respectivamente traducen qué pasa en mi
amar y escuchen la voz de mi amar los
ciudadanos que tienen acceso a estas
plataformas comparten imágenes de las
manifestaciones y denuncian la represión
de la fuerza pública con fotografías y
vídeos bastante crudos sobre la
situación
pero el ejército de mi amar podría
ampliar sus poderes para censurar a raíz
de las protestas la junta militar ha
propuesto leyes y ha hecho cambios
legales que ponen en peligro la
privacidad la libre expresión y el
acceso a la información en un país con
un amplio historial en represión uno de
los más polémicos es el proyecto de ley
de ciberseguridad que requiere que los
proveedores de internet retengan datos
de los usuarios y los entreguen a las
autoridades cuando se les solicite y
además los obliga a bloquear o eliminar
contenido que a juicio de los militares
se considere como noticias falsas o
información que cause odio o
intranquilidad delitos que serían
castigados hasta con tres años de
prisión un cambio que plantea riesgos
para activistas periodistas académicos y
cualquier persona que exprese su punto
de vista en línea según denunció human
rights watch
la ong birmana fort y fire rights
denuncia que la junta militar tiene en
la mira a periodistas y que más de 20
han sido detenidos desde el golpe de
estado mientras realizaban su trabajo
jhon william pérez especialista senior
en derechos humanos de esta organización
nos detalla la situación en el país
he hablado con periodistas en el estado
de china el estado de rakhine y en la
región de rangún que se han escondido
porque temen arrestos y represalias por
parte de las autoridades hay un número
de diferentes leyes que la junta de
mianmar está tratando de implementar que
limitaría la libertad en línea
la llamada ley de ciberseguridad podría
limitar severamente la capacidad de los
periodistas de reportar online
y los periodistas podrían ser acusados
por hablar de la junta militar
y por supuesto esto crea miedo y un
ambiente que no conduce a la libertad de
expresión y la libertad de reunión en el
país en estambul y en decanter y los
medios de comunicación del mundo han
destacado el trabajo de la población
civil para hacer resistencia a las
restricciones el portal británico the
guardian rescata que si bien desde hace
mucho tiempo se han organizado protestas
los manifestantes más jóvenes y
conocedores de internet han llamado la
atención del mundo con sus
demostraciones creativas carteles
inspirados en memes e ingenio mortal
la cadena de noticias de qatar al
jazeera dice que si los militares
esperaban que el apagón de internet y la
censura ayudaría a ocultar su creciente
brutalidad hacia los ciudadanos que han
salido a las calles eso no ha sucedido
la noche vélez de alemania advierte que
aunque las plataformas han ayudado a que
el movimiento de protesta ganará terreno
también pueden manipularse fácilmente
para distribuir información errónea
hasta aquí y revista digital recuerda
que si quieres repetir esta u otra
misión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
punto frente 4 punto com
[Música]